I'm usually not the biggest fan of
elected officials attacking other
elected officials without offering an
alternative a solution a proposal right
like I'm against just one elected
official slamming another for the hell
of it but I have to tell you there's an
exception to all rules in life or almost
all rules and I'm thrilled that Bernie
Sanders yesterday decided to rip Mike
Pence a new one after Donald Trump
selected him to run the coronavirus
response here in the United States
because this is not like many other
political issues you know debt and
deficit both sides use it to their
advantage they use it to appear to care
about one thing when in reality what
they care about is scoring partisan
points debt and deficit are not life and
death in the way that coronavirus
response is life and death
and indeed we are dealing with something
that is literally about life and death
and yesterday I told you that the
administration the Trump administration
is completely and totally unprepared to
deal with coronavirus I told you
yesterday that Donald Trump selecting
Mike Pence to run coronavirus response
is absolutely ludicrous Mike Pence is
the guy who wanted to pray for HIV to go
away in Indiana when he was governor he
at which by the way saw more than 200
people infected with HIV there and
Bernie went right in on him yesterday in
a tweet saying quote Trump's plan for
the corona virus so far cut winter
heating assistance for the poor have
vice president Pence who wanted to pray
away HIV epidemic oversee the response
let X Pharma lobbyists Alex Azhar
refused to guarantee affordable vaccines
to all disgusting Bernie also tweeted a
video of Alex's R who is now he's no
longer a Pharma lobbyist now he's the
Secretary of Health and Human Services
we're draining the swamp right saying
that he can't guarantee that if and when
a corona virus vaccine exists it will be
affordable to all take a look at the
video that Bernie
he also tweeted out yesterday reaffirm
then you're saying it will for sure be
affordable for anyone who needs it
I'm saying we would we would want to
ensure that we work to make it
affordable but we can't control that
price because we need the private sector
to invest the priorities control
secretary thank you there is a case to
be made that coronavirus is going to
help make the case for some kind of
single-payer public health care
everybody has coverage system and that
the case is going to be made very
quickly because rich people are going to
understand why it's important that
everyone have care as soon as they
realize wait a second if all these other
people can't afford a vaccine the odds
that I get coronavirus the odds that my
kids get it because no vaccine is 100%
effective go way up we need a system for
everyone to be able to both afford a
vaccine if we ever get one but also to
be able to get care if they contract
coronavirus and to add to my comments
yesterday about Mike Pence barely
believing in science like climate change
and somehow being in charge of
coronavirus it was pointed out to me
Mike Pence doesn't even fully believe in
evolution viruses evolve and mutate and
pens who is questioned evolution is
running the coronavirus response team
Pence has done this thing that some
religious rightists like to do will they
say listen we're not saying evolutions
not true but evolution is just a theory
and it should be taught alongside other
theories like God created everything for
example and of course this is where they
either don't understand or pretend not
to understand that the way you and I
might use the word theory in colloquial
language is very different than the way
that the scientific community uses the
word Theory Pence the funded planned
parenthood which studies have shown
reduces abortions by giving people
access to contraception and the only
thing I'm left wondering here I'm not
wondering whether Pence is up to the
task of doing this he's not
I'm not wondering whether Trump has any
idea how to pick the best people he
doesn't what I'm wondering is do you
think Trump on some level suspects that
Mike Pence obviously can't handle
running coronavirus response and Trump
is setting pence up to be the fall guy
if things go sideways but then if we're
lucky and we avoid disaster no thanks to
pence of course going for that then
Trump can say I told you guys I knew
that I was going to pick the right
person I picked Mike Pence and he was
able to get it done do you guys think
Trump may actually be thinking along
those lines or is he is he just really
incompetent and decided to put Mike
Pence in there because he thinks he can
actually handle this let me know what
you think privacy calm is one of our
sponsors and they're giving you $5.00
just for using their free service at
privacy calm slash Pakman privacy's of
service I've been using for a while now
I love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free and it's
very quick to set up and here's how it
works when you pay for something online
or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number privacy lets you generate
virtual card numbers the payments are
withdrawn from your checking account but
your real card number stays completely
private and you do it all with one click
you can autofill the card number in your
web browser on the phone you can create
12 virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a
no-brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft that costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend just for signing up when you go
to privacy comm slash Pakman